daniel robin bonjour bonjour monsieur
caruge vous n'êtes pas un nouveau en
politique on vous connaît déjà vous vous
présenter à ces élections législatives
quelles sont vos motivations pour
quelles raisons vous avez décidé d'être
candidat pour les législatives 2022 nous
avons une élection importante et il m'a
semblé important par rapport à ce que
les martiniquaises et les martiniquais
exprime c'est que ils ne se sentent pas
représentés il y avait besoin donc de
pouvoir offrir un visage une compétence
une expérience des connaissances qui
seraient susceptibles et je crois que je
suis porteur de tout cela j'ai entendu
beaucoup de colère aussi les
martiniquaises et martiniquais sont en
colère et surtout de manière très claire
je me positionne en opposition par
rapport au président de la république et
donc par rapport à sa majorité
présidentielle parce que je crois qu'il
est important que nous puissions ici à
la martinique avoir le plus de députés
possible qui siégeront dans l'opposition
vous avez milité dans des partis
politiques mais depuis quelques temps
votre discours vous le mettez sous le
label de la citoyenneté clairement parce
qu'il me semble aujourd'hui avec toutes
celles et tous seuls et qu'ils je
travaille depuis de nombreuses années
maintenant qu'il nous faut vraiment
restaurer le lien entre le citoyen et la
chose publique et on le voit comment à
travers la désaffection par rapport aux
élections qui se traduit par des niveaux
d'abstention très important donc il nous
semble important de et je suis entouré
de citoyennes et citoyens dans toute la
campagne parce que je crois que donner
du sens à la politique c'est repartir du
besoin des attentes de ceux qui font et
qui sont la clé de voûte de la
démocratie les citoyens alors quelles
seraient les deux ou trois projets
prioritaires pour le territoire que vous
auriez vous voulu voir défendu pourquoi
pas avec des textes de lois votées à
l'assemblée nationale pour la martinique
nationaux pour la martinique je crois
qu'il ya d'abord un enjeu majeur c'est
celui du pouvoir d'achat on le vide
toujours tous les jours il ya quelque
chose qui se passe et qui est assez
grave d'ailleurs c'est que ça conduit de
façon très mécanique à un problème de
précarité donc pouvoir d'achat précarité
tout ceci sur l'enjeu de ce qu'on
appelle la justice sociale ensuite je
suis sur un cheval de bataille qui est
l'emploi parce qu'il me semble important
aussi dans le cadre du contexte
martiniquais d'agir pour que les
martiniquaises et les martiniquais
puissent accéder plus facilement à
l'emploi ici localement et donc un
travail est en cours d'ailleurs nous
avons commencé à réfléchir sur tout ce
qui relèverait de la préférence
territoriales à l'emploi qui offrirait
donc l'opportunité dans un contexte où
il ya un vieillissement de la population
il ya des jeunes qui partent mais on va
se retrouver avec des besoins à couvrir
en terme de main d'oeuvre et que l'enjeu
c'est de pouvoir permettre aux résidents
d'y accéder ce serait possible sur le
plan législatif alors domine la
constitution française c'est possible
avec avec un certain nombre de
précautions le premier c'est la question
du contexte et de d'un rétablissement de
l'égalité donc la menace c'est qu'il y
ait de plus en plus de non résidents qui
accèdent à des emplois et l'autre chose
ça c'est une vraie audace la possibilité
de revendiquer ici à la martinique parce
qu'on appelle le service public
territorial de l'emploi qui est offert
aux régions mais donc aussi à la ctm
dans la mesure où la loi qui a été votée
au mois de février qui s'appelle cas de
décès un peu complexe mais autorisent
aujourd'hui de revendiquer sans passer
par un congrès sans faire des choses qui
serait complexe donc ce que cette
question de l'emploi soient domiciliés
ici à la martinique
concernant la circonscription dans
laquelle vous présentez qui est
particulière parce que c'est une ville
circonscription une circonscription
ville comme on voudra mais en tout cas
pour fort-de-france quelqu'un quel est
le ou les deux projets vous auriez voulu
voir mis en oeuvre rapidement alors
l'enjeu c'est de ne pas tomber dans une
démarche municipale puisqu'il s'agit
quand même d'une démarche législative
mais c'est vrai qu'il y à une
superposition de la commune et de la
circonscription mais ce que je crois et
à travers ce que les foyers les folie's
me renvoie il ya un un enjeu c'est quand
même celui de l'activité qu'il s'agisse
de la pêche de l'artisanat du commerce
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait à travers
donc un accompagnement et aussi dans un
partenariat avec la ville la possibilité
de porter une ambition pour l'avenir la
redynamisation des actualités activités
attractivité est exactement et donc
dinin redynamisation des activités
attractivité et bien évidemment logement
parce que il nous faut engager donc une
démarche où le logement pourra être au
centre de la vie à fort de france parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte notamment que
l'hyper centre c'est totalement des
peuples et donc l'ensemble de ces choses
est assez cohérent et c'est pour ça que
je crois qu'il ya besoin de plus de co
plus de partenariats pour conclure
qu'avez vous à dire essentiel
directement aux électrices et électeurs
de votre circonscription des chaires
électricien rédacteur je suis
aujourd'hui disponible je suis
totalement libre je ne suis plus encarté
dans aucun par un appareil politique et
mon engagement vis-à-vis de vous c'est
d'être totalement disponible pour un
seul mandat je ne ferai pas d'autre
mandat il est important que nous ayons
la possibilité de nous concentrer
ensuite j'appartiens maintenant à un
mouvement qui est un mouvement citoyen
fait de personnes qui sont comme vous en
rupture par rapport à la chose politique
donc je sais qu'il y a besoin de couvrir
vos attentes d'être vraiment connecté à
vos besoins être dans la proximité avec
vous et ce lien c'est ce que je veux
créer merci daniel robin d'avoir répondu
à nos questions merci